Урочисте винесення кубків жіночого
та чоловічого фіналів Ліги чемпіонів.
Київ відкриває для вболівальників чотири фан-зони.
На Хрещатику – головна - під назвою «Фестиваль чемпіонів».
Щоб ії створити, влада міста на півмісяці майже
повністю перекрила рух транспорту в центрі Києва.
Підготовка до Ліги і зустріч понад 50-ти тисяч фанів
Києву обійшлися у вісімсот сімдесят тисяч євро,
що в кілька разів менше витрат на Євробачення.
Місто готове…
Але можу сказати, що такого рівню спортивних
подій за історію міста Києва ще не було.
Ми вперше приймаємо такого рівня змагання.
Але, тим не менш, ми маємо досвід проведення
ЄВРО – 2012, Євробачення минулого року.
Ми можемо на дуже високому рівні проводити такі змагання.
На тлі свята МВС України заявляло про підвищений
рівень терористичної загрози.
СБУ не виключила кібератак з боку Росії.
Можливо, суто теоретична можливість зловмисників
зашкодити спокійному проведенню фіналу ліги чемпіонів .
Наразі СБУ вжито заходи з ліквідації і нейтралізації
хакерського угрупування , яке задіяне в цій атаці.
Про особливі заходи безпеки подбали на стадіонах,
де відбудуться жіночий та чоловічий фінали.
Також у аеропортах, які приймуть рекордну кількість чартерів з фанами.
Прикордонна служба готова пропускати туристів за
прискореною процедурою, окрім іноземців, які незаконно відвідували Крим.
Щоб запобігти зіткненням фанів, на вулиці Києва
вийдуть майже 22000 співробітників МВС, нацполіції та нацгвардії.
Фани будуть розділені. Під час матчу.
І ,безумовно, коли буде рух фанів до стадіону, ми
передбачаємо декілька маршрутів для заведення фанів різних команд
Особливо важливо по закінченні матчу повністю
взяти на контроль якраз фанів різних команд.
Фани ж насолоджуються радісним очікуванням
свята футболу і нічим не переймаються.
Іноземці…Вони ж мирні, вони не несуть жодного насилля.
Тим більше, що між «Реалом» і «Ліверпулем» немає
аж такого агресивного протистояння.
Не думаю, що щось станеться. Багато охорони навколо.
Я сподіваюся, що жодних бійок чи злочинів не буде,
що кожен насолоджуватиметься футболом.
І фани Ліверпуля, і фани Мадрида.
Мадрид переможе!
Сподіваюся, все пройде спокійно.
Мені здається, що Київ нічим не відрізняється від
будь-якого великого європейського міста.
Звичайно, є ризик. Але, де його нині немає?
Єдине, що сильно зіпсувало настрій багатьох фанів,
це занадто дорогі номери в київських готелях.
Щоправда, деякі готельєри не виключають,
що в останній день перед фіналом різко знизять
ціни з кількох тисяч євро до пари сотень.